you can defend an entirely different
view of the world with the same data
that's used to defend the standard model
so whenever I can do that I'm so there
because as soon as you realize that the
model you've been looking at maybe isn't
so firm as you thought then you're free
Scott Adams is a man of many talents
best-selling author behind books such as
gods debris and how to fail at almost
everything and still win big serial
entrepreneur are currently working on a
time management system called calendar
tree and of course creator of one of the
most successful comic strips of all time
Dilbert
but recently Adams has been making waves
at his blog where he's writing about the
persuasion tactics of current GOP
presidential frontrunner Donald Trump
who Adams calls a master wizard we sat
down with Adams in his home office to
talk about his Trump obsession his
political beliefs his philosophy of
failing towards success and naturally
Dilbert Scott thank you very much for
talking to us thanks for having me I
want to start with something a little
bit new Z which is Donald Trump you've
been writing about him at your blog the
Scott Adams blog and you say that it's
resulted in a five-fold increase in your
traffic what's your fascination with
Donald Trump and maybe more importantly
what's the public's fascination with
Donald Trump well he's a fascinating
character but my special fascination is
his ability to persuade his ability to
influence I have a background in
hypnosis I'm a trained hypnotist I
learned it years ago and I see in Trump
a level of persuasion technique that is
probably invisible to the public so I
like writing about it so they know I was
trying to think which Dilbert character
Trump is most like I was thinking cat
Bert but then I was like no it's
probably a loud Howard right oh I hadn't
thought about loud Howard but I think it
I would go with dog burp his dog bird in
the strip he makes billions of dollars
on a regular basis and he never gives it
back so there were internet rumors for a
while that you were libertarian or there
were speculation about that and you even
wrote an essay and response
appropriately titled
am i a libertarian and it quelled some
of those rumors but where do you
position yourself politically I try as
hard as I can not to fit in any of the
labels not to self label and to resist
anybody else's label because I feel it
affects credibility so not only does it
affect how someone else sees my opinion
because if they say oh he's one of them
they made
turn it off but it would affect me
internally as soon as I join a group as
soon as I say yeah I'm with these people
suddenly all those things that I thought
were crazy
I started convincing myself wow I don't
want to be a part of the crazy group so
maybe that crazy stuff makes sense after
all so I want to avoid all that if you
don't want to put a label on it
are there principles that you think are
best applied to the political realm or
the way that governments or officials
within government should operate yeah I
hate to sound like a trump supporter
here but my preferred political process
would be something like business now
what does business do all the time they
test things small that makes sense at
least that thing they're testing should
work you know it sounds good on paper
but they don't know so they test this
small we could do that with states
all right the states can test just about
anything and then the federal government
can say hey look at the results if it's
not enough test is somewhere else so I'd
like to see a world where things are
tested as soon as you leave that world
you're just it's just blah blah I can't
I can't find any way to agree with
anything that isn't come up with an idea
test it and measure it if you're not
doing that you're not doing anything I
care about I would love to see a
candidate who just says I don't have an
opinion I'm gonna go with the majority
on social issues just because that keeps
things you know calm and if it's
economics or world stuff and I can test
it I will libertarians tend to think
that you know that's why you leave as
many things to the marketplace as
possible because that's where ideas are
actually tested you have written that
the paradox of capitalism is that adding
a bunch of bad sounding ideas together
creates something incredible that is far
more good than bad and what led you to
that conclusion the amazing thing about
the economy and capitalism in general is
that most people are failing most of the
time nine and a ten new businesses fail
but while they're failing there are
people working for them they're buying
things foreign vendors and and even the
things that are succeeding they're only
succeeding until they don't right so
everything is a failure in progress they
just have temporary successes
sometimes so the genius of capitalism is
that it not only survives that failure
but it's built upon it all that activity
creates economic goodness for everybody
even though on the surface you can score
it a lot of it as a failure a lot of
people might be surprised to hear you're
generally good feelings towards
capitalism given that the Dilbert at
least on the surface kind of reads like
an indictment of it of forcing everyone
into this conformist box a literal box
in the shape of a cubicle is that a miss
reading of Dilbert capitalism falls into
that category of things which are
terribly flawed but nobody has a better
idea yet probably the better idea will
be some form of capitalism with some
kind of controls I would imagine so when
I talk about Dilbert and his life that's
really on the individual level if you're
an individual within capitalism you
could have a terrible life but you could
also have a wonderful life if you've
you're if you're lucky and you're born
in the right places and you do the right
stuff so capitalism is a mixed bag and I
write about some people who are or not
having the best of it before creating
Dilbert you were a kind of Dilbert
working at Pacific Val in some other
corporate environments you use your
experience there as template of what you
call failing towards success could you
talk about that idea so the idea of
failing towards success is really that
if you pick your projects carefully then
even in failure
you're gonna increase your odds for
something good happening later all right
so I I make the different the
distinction between a goal-oriented view
of life where you say this is the one
thing I want and you focus on that to
the exclusion of other things but
sometimes if you don't hit that goal
you're not really in a better position
for some other thing alright so I pick
projects where when they fail I'm
smarter I've learned something people
have met me I've networked there's
something about the situation that puts
me in a better situation you were
possibly the first cartoonist to put his
email address on the actual comic strips
and you say that it actually
revolutionized the comic strip and
was a huge boon for your career told me
about the decision to do that and what
happened after well so sounds so quaint
from the perspective of today but
including my email address in the
margins of the strip seemed radical at
the time because there was thinking that
it would be viewed as an advertisement
of some sort so if you could even think
back to an email was so new that people
thought it was more of an advertisement
than a communication
Dilbert was not terribly successful in
those days now I was sort of on a
failure vector at that point I wasn't
enough newspapers that I could have been
sustained so I had a little freedom the
freedom the failure gives you I have an
MBA and you know I'm an economics major
so I've got a lot of business the
background and cartoonists typically
didn't use any business principles so
the biggest most important one you know
number one is you got to open a channel
to your customers and say how am i doing
and if you're not doing well you got to
change something right it's the most
basic thing any business does no
cartoonist had ever done that there was
always the cartoonist sends it out and
it goes through channels and the shows
up in the newspaper and strangers read
it and that's all you know so once I put
my email and address in the strip people
wrote in and said we'd love that with
Dilbert's in the office we don't like it
when he's at home and that in those days
he was mostly a home and I didn't know
that people liked him in the office so
much but it was a pretty clear message
so I made that change and that was
probably the biggest change that made
Dilbert successful exactly like the
business books would say it should
happen I listened to the customers I
changed the product and by moving him
into the office it seems that she really
tapped into I don't know the zeitgeist
of what was going on in corporate
America at that time and people really
related to it and now there's been some
self-conscious changes away from the
cubical farms to these like open floor
plans and you can telecommute and bring
your dog to work and everything what do
you make of today's corporate
environment is it improvement or is it
just repackaging of the same stuff well
you have to be careful especially in the
Bay Area you know where I live you hear
about the startups in the open offices
and everybody's bringing their dog to
work that is not corporate America
corporate America is still the cubicle
you know things aren't changing that
quickly
so the startup world is its own hole you
know ecosystem that's a whole different
deal I'm trying to incorporate some
changes into Dilbert
he doesn't wear his necktie anymore I
just sort of silently took that away and
I just put him in sneakers for the first
time you won't see that comic for a
month or so but making small changes to
acknowledge that the world moves do you
think it's moving in a positive
direction negative direction or is it
just the same lateral every time there
are more options it's a better world you
can't make people choose options you
can't manage their risk for them well I
think the world has more opportunity
both inside a corporation and out then
it ever has at anytime and more
opportunity for every person in society
so I would say it's the best it's ever
been by far is there a theme that runs
through all of your work there is and
even though it looks like different work
there's I've written books of fiction
there's the cartoon and I've written
non-fiction books but in all cases I'm
interested in the same thing which is is
there a different way to look at the
familiar is there another way to look at
the the office work situation is there
another way to look at reality is there
another way to look at why Donald Trump
is doing well so whenever there's a
another explanation
I don't even require that to be the
better one or the preferred one or even
mine but I find it terribly interesting
that you can defend an entirely
different view of the world with the
same data that's used to defend the
standard model so whenever I can do that
I'm so there
because as soon as you realize that the
model you've been looking at maybe isn't
so firm as you thought then you're free
you write a lot about persuasion and
kind of being able to reprogram people
through hypnosis and whatnot but is
there a place for rational discourse
there's a room for logic and reason in
this world there is but it's limited to
the example I use is if you're balancing
your checkbook which I haven't done for
years but I hear people do it you're
using reason and
if you're doing something that's a very
constrained usually human artificially
constrained situation logic is really
good in that reason works really well
but in the real world there are always
too many variables you're and you're
really you're just left to your biases
so what we learn in hypnosis is that
almost all reasons given for the big
decisions in life are rationalizations
after the fact the little stuff like why
did you pick this product over this one
it might have been price it might have
been reasonable but the big stuff where
do you live who'd you marry what
decisions do you make all irrational so
you just embrace the irrationality I do
more than that because the irrational
'ti is useful right
once you learn that it is what it is and
how do you how to use it and the tools
for living that world it's completely
transparent if there's so many competing
ideas and they can all be defended about
equally how do you decide which ones to
go with I don't believe in a preferred
view of the world in other words I don't
believe there's a preferred reality I'm
kind of you know cheating I'm borrowing
a sort of an Einstein thought about
physics and applying it to our
perceptions but I think anything that
doesn't kill you works in other words my
neighbor can believe that President
Obama is a Kenyan Muslim who's
destroying the presidency from the
inside before he gives a Rand the bomb
to kill us all and I could believe that
none of that's happening but we both go
to the grocery store and we're standing
next to each other and we're buying
melons and nobody dies right so there
are a lot of competing ideas that just
seem to work they fit the data well
enough they don't die and then they
survive so I I guess I would only
caution humility about your own view
because I I assume that most of my views
are wrong because they're different than
they used to be right and I thought they
were pretty right before so the fact
that I'm sure I'm a little bit more
right now probably there's no more data
that says I'm right now than I was
before and I've changed my mind
it takes a long time to learn some
humility about how much you really know
it scott adams thank you very much
thanks for having me for reason TV I'm
Zach Weiss
what it is is a worldview sort of a
filter if you will and way to look at
the world to try to understand things
that don't make sense with whatever
model of the world you are looking at
before